when we talk today about the defensiveness
speak of our democracy,
I think the parliamentarian must be clear to everyone,
our free democratic basic order
no millimeter must be doubted.
there must be no yes but.
and for us it must be clear,
who starts from an image of man,
knows the citizen 1st and 2nd class,
who divides the statevolg according to ethnic groups,
it's ingeschichtsvergessener,
I say it so clearly in a disgusting way,
on the foot of war
with our free democratic basic order.
everywhere it is 1 narrow degree,
1 narrow degree between dangerous lunatic
and crazy dangerous.
that's why we have to look very closely.
but it can't be,
that any criticism of the federal government,
in particular any criticism of their migration policy,
is reinterpreted by them as anti-democratic,
radical right,
racist.